je ressens
[Applaudissements]
les eu de la chance il y à déjà ici avec
des cadeaux dedans vous avez un petit
marteau faudra casser l'oeuf a
délicatement les cherry à manger après
bien entendu joseph tu peux remettre le
truc à kelly elle remercie et on va voir
les cadeaux qu'il y a gagné ce soir il
ya un costume de poule à mettre
immédiatement de pâques
l'agent bbox l'agent bbox je vais vous
dire de quoi il s'agit là jean bbox
alors l'agent bbox ah oui c'est une
boîte avec tout le nécessaire
voilà pour pour faire du bien et pour
passer la pommade à son patron grosse
allende dictionnaire des compliments etc
merci on a une journée avec un
ambassadeur en fait c'est une journée
dans un parc d'attractions qui vont
remballer ça c'est super puisque
l'ambassadeur de ce parc c'est maxime
donc voilà donc c'est une journée que
maxime donc on a mis des mauvais cadeau
un oreiller dédicacé par doc gynéco mais
on a une enceinte bluetooth waterproof
un écran géant ah ouais consoles de jeux
dernière génération une trottinette
électrique et en week-end de pakistanais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un week-end de
pâques et cette année un week end au
pakistan pas du tout c'est un week end
avec moi un week-end avec moi et avec
moi mais collé serré août et quelle
cadence et haoues était prêt partant
pour nous tes calais et on savait déjà
où ils sont tombés sur des versions ce
week-end les versions wii ainsi
actuellement mon coeur vous qui savez
tout ça sert à quoi d'avoir une enceinte
comme sous l'eau une ancienne combien
souleva ça fait du bien là mais cela
devant les finales à la douche
oui elle a donc je suis ça mais vous
prenez peut-être pas de douche c'est
hier j'ai une autre question est ce
qu'un prime time dans l'oeuf une arena
lors d'un prime time dans l'oeuf
allons je vous dis qu'est ce que ça veut
dire une journée avec moi un week-end je
peux rallonge été mis en retrait de
faire même l'émission 101 printemps dans
le bassin est aussi drôle à passer
alors donc choisir vos on va aller donc
du plus âgé au moins âgée qui va choisir
son oeuf
forcément c'est blanc fait réfléchir oui
c'est vrai la belle isabelle vous avez
choisi en premier ep de courtois vous
prenez call of fait poindre le bleu non
mais si je mens chiffres de 1 à 10 à 9,9
en bas oui mais alors on l'avait mais
deschamps ne nous intéressait les jeunes
je vous le mets là attention
ensuite jean mi le trois saisons
pêcheurs le 3 je lé là il est magnifique
je vous le messie merci ça fera 3 euros
qu'est ce qu'il veut c'est ce qu'il veut
le jeune homme alors j'ai donc sur le
jura dans ces mois-là plus vient à huy
cebenna il exactement
oui mais je vais vous prendre s'il vous
plaît vous êtes vous auriez l'a7 la 7e
journée stop
il nous reste à la merci je vous mets je
vous même temps que tu l'as pas choquant
même été lancé ce we
[Applaudissements]
en flic le dessus le 2 je lai le 2 est
magnifique je vous le mets merci boîtier
de leur nom c'est d'abord à la personne
un pascal numéro le 7 le seigle et nabi
salih déjà pris en allah et douce et du
bourdalat la 3d a pris aussi découvre
alors j'ai pas papa namsa à calais je
sais pas ce qui est dans mon travail en
avril 5 voilà jeu mature ce que vous
voulez mais en sus également alors le 1
le à bah voilà le un regard des comme il
est beau je vous donne neuf numéros
comme le chroniqueur préfet la niva
ensuite dans une éco jeu lancé raymond
d'abord raymond à 42 tirs et mons et
raymond il reste quoi là ce qu'ils ont
placé jean et oui ces dates il reste le
6 le 4 le disent à quel âge - 2 vs 2 4 2
x 2 4 ça marche aussi à l'airé saucisses
le disent alors un seul 10 10 pour moi
de 10 très bien numéro 10 bien entendu à
la fête
il reste le 6 et le et le 8 qu'est ce
que vous choisissez le but
le 8 voilà très bien et kelly nous a dit
le numéro 6 à la toiture est parti on va
démarrer avec
isabelle morini-bosc c'est vous qui avez
choisi votre enfant premier isabelle est
ce que vous voulez casser votre offre
une scène c'est le seul lieu qui me
restent même alors fait jouer cas c'est
bien sûr mais maintenant levé le canard
oui mais les frags vous voulez qu'ils
nous votre art au filet et on n'a pas le
temps là donc si vous pouviez merci aux
croisades sûr que vous prenez le neuf
oui je prends de neuf parce que ça
m'arrive s'est toujours dressé toujours
les radiations alors ces gens dire de
vous emporter par bah non il était il
est ouvert mais si parce qu'en fait on
en levant sa nasse pas besoin de casser
je viens de lesquin fallait se méfier
des trucs je viens de comprendre et
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça et comme
quoi vous avez gagné une journée avec un
ambassadeur avec maxime des dilemmes et
merci d'ailleurs merci d'ailleurs acquis
à quelqu'un qui s'appelle jsf voilà et
qui vient de belgique
voilà merci très bien vous à des
personnes sourdes avec maxime dany s'il
vous plaît on se craint attention
géraldine m'a dit moi je garde le peuple
voulait donc je garde
je pense que c'est une bonne regardez
l'offre numéro qu'est ce qui vous ferait
plaisir
j'aimerais bien être qu'il est
électrique pour ma fille c'est vrai vous
aimeriez bien la trottinette électrique
pour jean louis reiffers la trottinette
un week-end avec sita est ce que j'ai
bâti quotidiennement bel et bien
géraldine maillet voulait accrocher net
écrit aimerait bien malheureusement vous
avez la trottinette
[Applaudissements]
antidatés
ces choses et son beau je te jette au
liera à castel de soginorpa 7e flat
voulait pas s'éteindre un nom voulait
qu'elle est l'oeuvre de de lambeaux
alors je vous le dis je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils analysaient là-dessus si oui je
suis parti une fois comme cyril mais je
suis moi je suis leader tnt
je suis j'aimerais échanger vos neuf et
prendre celui de benjamin cannes en
finale dernier il a choisi c'est terminé
vous voulez donc 7e vrai c'était celui
de matthieu delormeau rappelle mathieu
qu'est-ce que vous aurez fait plaisir
attendez je vous le dis connu benjamin
castaldi franchement mathieu vous en
vouloir
pourquoi parce que c'est le plus beau
cadeau que vous avez gagné un kastali un
oreiller dédicacé par toi
[Musique]
c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
s'appelle les chiffres n'ont même pas
mis deux ou cinq semaines
le huit césar dix ans qu'il n'y a pas
besoin du trad
le 8 puis je vais le conserver
ce que vite et symbole de l'infini ah
oui bah oui quand on est comme ça le
symbole de vie alors le 8 qui vous fait
plaisir à ma petite console de jeux
vient d'ouvrir les joueurs maxime gagner
gagner pour pâques
et bien sûr vous êtes associé à un
téléspectateur une enceinte nous tous
[Musique]
mc gainey il nous il a fait je sais pas
si vous connaissez chez vous le super du
gars qui viendront cac gagne 1 cd rom
donc jean félix houphouët vous ne gagnez
un cd rom sur le shopping
je voulais les enceintes pour de 10
camions le dise il ya plus de cadeaux
maintenant si le sait il ya les
crawleurs ce qui lui ferait plaisir mais
je voulais les enceintes mais l'écran
c'est bien aussi
l'écran et vous ferez plaisir avoué je
réponds pas je viens la vérité la place
en séries la chambre commune tous les
deux à ben voilà qu'avec vous je risque
pas de s'en tire beaucoup de choses
le costume de pouilly clé raymond on
connaît de gagner ça me fait très
plaisir une console de jeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la ligue 1 0 sec oui elle garde sa mêlée
benhaim question ferait plaisir
eh ben le week-end avec toi we can am
raoui avec moi et c'est non et sinon
qu'est-ce que si nous qu'est-ce qu'il ya
eu bel écran benhaim vous gagnez un
magnifique cadeau est ce que vous gagnez
un collier de pacte a tout de suite à
benhaim merci voilà men amc pour vous
c'est ciao pas comme ça mais vous avez
notre mission n'est que trois puces a
fait quatre jeux prendre celui de doc
gynéco tête avec les motifs bas le twin
alors qu'est le 4 janvier vous gardez le
4 je prends le 4 à battre est bien pour
vous quoi jean-mi box est qu'à son
niveau m'a dit l'agent du box bourges
l'école qui commence par soi flipper la
cie attention il ne reste qu ils restent
3es warrior king size
il reste 3e ce genre de quel côté du dit
ouah qu'est ce qu'il vous reste un écran
géant lorie kane avec moi le cossu de
poules qu'elle dit est ce que vous
conservez le loeuff numéro 6 jeux le
concerne c'est sûr
manquaient les voleurs gars de neuf est
ce que tu veux losc 1 0 6 tu gardes le 3
c'est pas les deux sont bien là 3 x 2
allait elle garde le sis au calice
histoire
j'ai dit qu'il souffrait plaisir
j'aimerais un métro géant est bien calé
un écran géant non
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire à tout le monde de se
calmer je vous le dis le scénario n'a
pas été qu'une bataille scénario n'a pas
été écrit je vous le jure que c'est vrai
il reste 2 à 2,5 et 3 et le 3 dans tous
les cas tu vas être bien donc dans tous
les cas vous jeu grâce à un week end
avec matthieu delormeau ou avec doc
gynéco préférence oui alors on parle on
ne parle pas de préférence je alors je
vous dis il y a ou à costumes de plus à
mettre immédiatement ou un week-end de
pakistanais
mathieu est ce que vous conservez votre
numéro 5
voici le pr neil trois noms sont finies
les bons gagnera c'est maintenant non
race et de carrés de sa c4
je vais garder le 5 à thaksin et causent
tous voulaient le centre de foires
caussinus de 5 c 3 vous nous rappelez
des jeux ouverts tout de suite non lof
numéro 5
donc ça qui va là bas je repasserai t
smithzz
je ne serai ton corps en tant d'aisance
demierre
[Applaudissements]
il y en a tant brillé dans la main le
cadeau de mathieu de mathieu est ce que
c'est le costume de poule ou est ce que
c'est le week end avec moi mais je t'en
dire de miel s'était encore pendant le
week end
il y avait des cadeaux dans des oeufs on
est parti bien sûr cette marque
magnifique qui commence par un quine et
qui finit par under qui signifie enfants
dans la lente dead moon coll
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et oui on est parti de ça et on s'est
dit on va mettre des cadeaux dans des
oeufs
les téléspectateurs peuvent partager
bien sûr les cadeaux avec le chroniqueur
de leur choix et bien sûr on a lancé le
http est pour l'instant le hasard a fait
les choses comme jamais ne les a fêtés
c'est à dire parfaitement serfaty
unanime est reparti avec la souris
plutôt lozahic est fait ici on comprend
à peine plus tard jean michel maire jean
michel maire oui le chef est parti avec
moque situons michel mr bon vous avez
gagné dans san bluetooth et sincères
cadeaux moyens oui mais là bas on peut
rire c'est mon préféré objections paul
kelly vdev ni à gagner une télé on sait
qu'elle a des problèmes de télé en ce
moment mais vous vous avez gagné une
console de jeux c'est votre kif vous
vous avez gagné
ils ont aimé qu'un agent exactement
sédatifs et vous vous avez gagné
électrique le rêve de ma fille ni la
trottinette électrique tout meilleurs da
gagné locales et l'oreiller si on sait
que castanet jamais dans dix d'entre eux
n'avait pas dit il est déjà heureux en
amour et peut pas d'emploi toro ouais je
tapais ciré l'on partage qu'on était des
spectateurs du coup on va couper votre
console en doute
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire qui va gagner aussi la
console de jeux la mise à jour vient est
resté deux cadeaux un costume de poule à
mes tripes
de vendredi à dimanche soir sur un court
mais comme on partage les cadeaux il y
aura aussi quelqu'un qu'on connaît
passera qui viendra également sur wii il
y aura certainement quelqu'un alors
c'est moi qui ai choisi ce que j'ai un
pote qui vous qui beaucoup il est blond
c'est fait j'ai rencontré ce week-end à
8 ans vous une bombe à martin et vous
vous allez faire arthur choisir c'est
moi faire voyons déjà pour l'instant
vous calmer puisque les téléspectateurs
veulent savoir qui a gagné le costume de
poule et vale met immédiatement et qui a
gagné le week-end de pakistanais
j'ai ici dans la main le cadeau de leur
numéro 5 qui était l'offre de matthieu
delormeau maturation la vie n'a pas
changé
est-ce que vous conservez non je vous le
jure sur la tête de la toya jackson sur
la toya jackson wall alan martin est
vrai que je n'ai pas changé le cadeau
mathieu durand moi ce que vous gardez ce
cadeau-là le cadeau qu'ils étaient dans
l'oeuf numéro 5
comme disait etienne daho il n'est pas
de hasard il n'est que des rencontres je
garde mon 5
les références savoir dis donc c'est pas
mal un top soit cnl champlain doc gynéco
garde donc le cadeau numéro 3 oui c'est
long au niveau des lunettes
merci c'est une phrase matthieu
delormeau
c'est votre cadeau que je vais montrer
vous rêvez un week-end avec moi et
réciproquement
non à la cause c'est matthieu delormeau
ramé mois le costume c'est un maître
immédiatement matthieu delormeau
malheureusement une fois de plus à y
perdre
taipei de chant dans la douleur je vous
jure que je n'ai pas changé papier
voulez je vous montre ce qu'avait dans
le papier numéro 3 ouais bien numéro 3
et là je le montrerai après ski adam
papier numéro 3 donc je vous le dis
matthieu delormeau
si vraiment il ya un costume je vois les
caméras thuram avec plaisir joli on
montrera tout regarder la ferme était
parmi nous je vous donne le costume de
cool matthieu delormeau
vous pouvez commencer à l'enfiler
j'aurais préféré le numéro 3
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il n'a pas montré votre cadeau que j'ai
dans les batailles malheureusement vous
gérez une fois de plus six mois scénario
une fois que je regardais regarder ce
qu'il devait faire
regardez là on en reste là elle se
laisse regarder
je veux que ça s'affiche sur le s'il
vous plaît sur le barco derrière
demandez pas trop là s'il vous plaît en
régie jean-jacques amsellem il a fait
des finales de coupe du monde et leurs
exportateurs
je veux ce plan je veux le plan là le
plan là sur ce plan là et arrêtez de
mettre de la musique ou quoi que ce soit
le plan de la caméra
allez on y va tiens au fait merci avant
la mise en abyme warriors c'est
magnifique matthieu delormeau
c'est un peu trop gros plan c'est
marquer
la moitié
on entendra là
mais bon
à l'aller
[Applaudissements]
matthieu aron guen le week end avec moi
l'école
[Applaudissements]
28 déc aux costumes de boules de poils
costume tue van lede turian ouvert dans
un instant